yeah i'm just gonna stay i'm in brooklyn
in the [ __ ] thick of it
and there's a part of me that wants to
go but now i don't know i may there's
it's like should i go just go down with
the ship but that's stupid too
right bill because it's like that's what
i'm doing in l.a
you're going down with the ship you're
not gonna move to austin like everybody
like half of my friends at this point
have either
died got cancelled or are now leaving la
so i'm just feeling like i feel like a
fifth year senior in high school right
now like
like where did everybody go so it's been
um
yeah it's been a definitely uh
definitely weird definitely weird i've
been fighting off uh
having the blues wouldn't quite help
depression but i definitely
have been fighting that type of [ __ ] off
so i've been trying to throw myself
into other things i got some socially
distant
shows coming out um how was how was
going to dave chappelle's thing
oh man it was incredible and um heard
you made a lot of money
uh oh yeah man hand over fist i bought
the next town over from dave
um i basically uh no dude he [ __ ]
flew us all in
it was like a paid vacation and then i
got to do [ __ ]
um i got to do stand-up the way it used
to be
everybody's phones were locked and there
was this oh my god i can say whatever i
want to say
and i don't have to deal with white
chicks trying to end my [ __ ] career
or or just the idea of it um which i'm
really hoping the same way
90s clothes went out of style
that when all of this is over this whole
um sort of comedy um
what was that thing uh mccarthyism that
they're doing and the way people
like i think there's [ __ ]
comedians
that are are just co-signing on
accusations
when it's like it might happen might not
have happened
and they're like trying to help take out
these guys
is uh it was pretty eye-opening
and then it's weird when you run into
one of those comics and you know that
they're the ones that
will just go with what anything is said
and then they say hello to you and you
just kind of look at them like
uh hi until somebody says 20 years ago i
sneezed on their [ __ ] burrito or some
[ __ ] and then
then you're it's like i know who you are
i know what you're good
you're gonna do so i i just find the
whole thing it's just such a bizarre
bizarre [ __ ] time you know yeah
there's no comedy community now it's
you everyone's your potential enemy
there is 95
of comics are not doing that and um
i i just really think it just says a lot
to me about a person
you know because a lot of the times too
it's not just like look obviously
if somebody has like [ __ ] you know 30
women coming out
okay i know the person still didn't get
a trial
but i mean it's like what the [ __ ] how
did you get 30 people to all
have roughly the same story like i get
all of that but like
my thing is was when they then delve
into it my favorite thing is
then you see them just slowly start
criticizing the comedians act
and all of this [ __ ] you start to be
like oh wait a minute now let's let's
try to stay on
uh let's try to keep it on the road here
remember what you're outraged about
you're outraged about these uh alleged
victims you're not outraged about how
this person was getting more spots than
you were
at the [ __ ] chuckle huts so it's
definitely um
yeah it seems like so you just have to
you just have to say hi
back and because it's because it's you
know air quote not worth it
but i mean it's it's hard from for uh
i don't know i mean i don't like to live
my life not saying what i'm feeling
so but it's it is it is what it is as
they say isn't that you're irish though
isn't kind of
that what you guys do isn't that y'all's
deal i'm mostly german
well it was a german kid like me a lot
of movies
about irish people i don't know what
irish people are like because
uh i'm mixed with a bunch of different
euro white european [ __ ] so i would i
would go to ireland to find out what
they're like
but um you know german and irish yeah
you guys are you guys aren't as
that effusive with your emotions it's
more more cerebral
i know and you guys have big fat greek
weddings i also watch hollywood movies
about your [ __ ] you know
so dude only the whole if only the hall
of fame
white guys are going to dave chappelle's
camp you
ck john stewart you got to be hall of
fame white
if you want to get invited to chappelle
yeah not middle of road white ain't
getting that [ __ ] call babe it's the
big league whites
and listen we deserve it i'm not mad at
fort it's like yeah what the [ __ ]
i get it what did i ever do for you we
really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild